is building his own place he's building
his own place in Yellow Springs in Ohio
yeah it's called The Firehouse it used
to be an actual Firehouse well is there
going to be a pole over the stage I
don't know that would be cool that'd be
great I don't know if it's still there
like you know I mean maybe it's been
something since then but it used to be a
firehouse and um having him come out and
checking this out and then he's like
dude now I'm inspired so whatever he's
gonna do in Yellow Springs gonna be very
interesting because it's I think he's
doing 120 seats holy [__] if he's doing
a size the size of little boy damn dude
yeah imagine that like you can go see
Dave Chappelle at any given night in his
backyard what a great idea though like
he's Dave Chappelle he could do that
anywhere like why not why not like build
your own club and have the people come
to you because of course they're going
to come to see Dave it'll be a vacation
destination like like your Club is
people were from all over the world last
night to kill Tony